speaking of some sort of villain the
media and the journalists around town
have made andy know out to be a villain
and andy
it's impossible for me to find someone
who has probably done better
journalistic work
in the last couple years uncovering what
antifa is although jack obviously you've
done a quite job
quite a good job yourself so andy was
attacked in portland by a bunch of
antifa activists the other day this will
not be covered on cnn today
this will not be covered on msnbc and
i'm guessing it ain't going to be in the
new york times
andy sent out a long twitter thread
about it i'm just going to read the two
first ones
and then we're going to show you some
some images of of what happened to him
uh this is directly from andy himself no
journalist in america should ever face
violence for doing his or her job
yet on friday may 28th antifa tried to
kill me again while i was reporting
on the ongoing protests and riots in
portland oregon for a new chapter of my
book
unmasked inside antifa's radical plan to
destroy democracy
i was chased attacked and beaten by a
masked mob
baying for my blood had i not been able
to shelter
wounded and bleeding inside a hotel
while they beat me
while they beat the doors and windows
like animals there is no doubt in my
mind
i would not be here today their words
like their actions speak for themselves
he went on in the twitter thread and uh
if we can can we throw to some of the
images
uh while i'm mentioning this i as i said
at the top of the show i actually met
andy at that hotel years ago for the
first time
first time we ever met each other he's
the most soft-spoken
decent guy you could ever want to meet
this is not someone
that wants to be involved in violence or
inflaming the situation or anything else
uh jack because you're you're you know
writing a book or you just wrote a book
and you're also talking about antifa all
the time
why is this not being covered in an
honest way and what do you think is
andy's responsibility as a journalist
journalist knowing he's going to be
targeted there because i saw a couple
people
who i usually respect their opinions
sort of being like oh no no he shouldn't
have gone there which is kind of like
telling a woman
she shouldn't you know go out alone at
night
oh yeah well you know to just kind of
answer the second part of that you know
i i would definitely if that were me i'd
you know i'd want to have some security
i'd want to have some backup you know
have them
also be dressed in you know sort of the
the black garb of the black block you
know have them look like they're
infiltrating not carrying weapons or
anything like that unless of course the
black block already is in which case
fine go for it
but yeah um i i get what people are
saying that obviously we
want andy to be safe we we know that we
want people out there watching his back
um i i hope that that's something that
we can you know we can get going in the
future when this comes up because
the real situation is is that when it
comes to this organization they are an
anarcho-communist
syndicate at this point that is pushing
for violence
in all of these major cities across the
country we saw them in minneapolis again
just last night
and the the not only the media gives
them a pass right
the media will they'll hand out these
little flyers when you go out and they
say if you want to cover one of our
events you have to
abide by our rules and we talk about
this in the book
where you know you can't show our faces
you can't show any action you can't sow
any violence you can't show
anything that could identify us and as
long as you abide by those rules and
basically take our side and everything
and don't do
actual journalism then we'll treat you
fine if not
we're going to put umbrellas in your
face we're going to attack you or like
in my case they're gonna we're gonna try
to push you down
concrete steps to get you to crack your
head open in front of a
statue in lincoln park there in dc and
so when it comes down to it though the
bigger problem
on a higher level is why is the
department of justice
not going after these people we've seen
the way that they've treated january 6
tweeting out the pictures having the
asking people to help identify
where's any of that for antifa they are
just as much insurrectionist insurgents
they're out there night after night and
when it comes to the city of portland
they're attacking
actual federal facilities well weren't
we told that you're allowed to attack
federal facilities as long as it's at
night and nobody's in there wasn't that
literally
the mayor of portland that said that no
it would no unfortunately that was our
attorney general merrick garland who
said that during his uh
oh right right confirmation hearings so
my question is what if it's dusk what if
it's like
right on the cusp of it you know you're
it's like
it's like you know before a hockey game
and you're there with the sticks and
you're like ready to go
no right exactly what's silly it's silly
right what if somebody's working late
i mean it is possible i know it's the
government and obviously there are
we know there are people in there
because there were federal agents in the
building at the time so yes
uh attorney general garland there were
people working there they were working
to defend
the courthouse against the thugs that
you won't bring
charges against steve to jack's point i
mean
do you think the feds are going to get
involved i mean
finally the mayor of portland ted
wheeler started pushing back against
them a little bit
after he basically poured gas on the
flames for the last
two years i mean do we need the feds to
be involved why are we letting mass
thugs burn down our cities crazy
question i know
i i well i i thought they should have
been dealt with as a
foreign hostile power for declaring they
had a nine block
uh independent zone last summer frankly
uh and made an example out of
but no they won't be dealt with until or
unless it impacts the overall
leftist narrative and then that's when
uh they'll learn really quick that the
first rule of assassination is that you
kill the assassins
and i want to go back for just a second
on the cognitive dissonance
aspect and with with andy and and the
bravery of what he has been doing for
these last couple of years
so yesterday my publisher sent me a
piece that the atlantic had written
about uh what had been some of the more
successful conservative books so far
in the biden admit in the biden era
which you know is what six months old
and the the highest selling book within
conservative publishing
so far this year is actually andy's book
on antifa and this was mentioned by
mckay coppins
the writer at the atlantic who
specifically mentioned it by name
now where again so you acknow
we i want to make sure we remove all the
innocent motivations here
all right you're citing the success of
this guy's book you're citing that it's
the most successful book
in a genre this entire year so either
he's a total fraud
making a bunch of slanderous and
libelous claims who should be exposed
or he's exposing a thugocracy it's one
or the other
aren't you at least the least bit
intellectually curious
which one it is right and of course the
irony is that everybody that writes a
piece now about andy
in mainstream media or corporate press
whatever you want to call them as
michael malus puts it
they always make a point of saying
conservative journalist andy no
now i mentioned on twitter i mean i know
andy pretty well he by no means is a
traditional conservative again
he's gay not that you can't be a gay
conservative but the point is i think
he's probably an old school liberal
who's just
been for lack of a better term mugged by
reality in this case
honestly i i yeah i've i've talked to
andy a million times
i have no idea what his politics are
yeah
he's a journalist so i don't know
because we've
he's never even brought it up yeah i'm
totally with you on that i mean i have a
slight inkling on some things but in no
way when they say conservative it's
they're trying to paint him
as as something that he probably is not
um what about just the general idea that
either journalists can now be attacked
or just what we saw in new york
and in la in the last couple weeks that
you can just attack random people on the
streets
and that this this right seems like it's
being
uh exacerbated it's just a sad state of
affairs that now look at all the bad
journalism that is happening right now
with mainstream media that goes
completely unaccountable
and you have andy noe who is a great
journalist who is doing very good work
and is simply telling the truth and that
is his reward for what he's doing
and anybody who comes out and says
anything that criticizes the left
especially the extreme left
is labeled a conservative journalist
even though like you said he's not very
apparent about where he
lies politically and it's a very sad
state of affairs and we see all these
politicians who say well antifa is just
an idea
it doesn't represent a terrorist
organization they're not doing anything
domestically that's causing any harm to
america but last time i checked ideas
don't
mob people they don't trample them and
beat them down in the streets
right well exactly i mean if any of
these things that we've seen in the last
two years could be linked back to trump
supporters as jack pointed out
uh after what happened on the six it was
it would be like they'd be telling us
we're in world war three
jack do you think we're going to find
links between
antifa and the democratic party or at
least some
something more tangible than they seem
to tacitly support them
well so what you really see in the in
the dichotomy or i should say like the
dynamic between
antifa and the democrat party is
that antifa exists to be that leading
edge the tip of the spear
of the overton window with antifa talk
about this and
go to antifa book.com and see it um
shameless in the shameless book
and uh what you see is
then the democrats are increasingly the
dsa word antifa recruits from
uh you know it's really just in many
cases the dsa at night with masks
and black shirts on but they can say
well look we're not as extreme as antifa
we don't want to
abolish the police we just want to
change the funding we just want to
tweak a few things you can actually see
joe biden do this
in real time when they ask him about
some of these antifa dsa slogans where
he says oh no
i just want to i just want to recommit
things i want to change it so
that's exactly how you see nt for
working and by the way
when people tell me is antifa just an
idea right i look at them and i say well
radical islam is just an idea but you
know what
they've got cells they've got groups
they've got organizations and they
commit terrorist attacks so yeah they're
an idea
that forms a movement that starts a
network that has splinter cells
that gets people hurt and gets people
killed so sure why not
but if you you sound like a lunatic if
you you just saying that in 2021 that
native is just an idea
yeah great point steve as a guy that
tries to communicate
these ideas to people um
what can we do to actually show people
that this thing is exactly what jack
just pointed out and not just some
amorphous idea
i think they have to be confronted on a
legal
matter political matter uh on a military
matter
frankly i think they should be treated
if they if if it was
islam that claimed to occupy nine city
blocks of a major american city i would
assume
we would treat that as a hostile
invading force and
one of the things that's puzzled me
about antifa this entire time is it just
me
okay but every time one of these kids
gets one of these guys gets unmasked
doesn't it look like when we were in
youth football and you're like
slowly going into the line you're sizing
up when the oklahoma drills coming up
and you're like
i don't want to be opposite this guy so
let me let these three guys go ahead of
me
every one of them is like the dweeb you
gave swirlies to in the
locker room right it's like they
specifically
target guys who are taking humanities or
women's studies with a why
in college 301 and think and fantasize
at night about being a badass because
uh they they played some military
first-person shooter game once i mean
why do all of these guys whenever
they're unmasked look like complete and
total dweebs
wait actually i want to before i give
them all the final word i want to ask
jack that very question because when you
see these pictures of these people when
they finally are unmasked
steve's totally right and also it seems
that a huge
percentage of them are on drugs and we
know that there's obviously an opioid
and fentanyl
crisis right now do you have any info on
that like how many of these people are
actually hooked on drugs and
how that is all connected so when i when
i was in chaz
you know we talk about this in the book
as well but when i spent uh you know the
several days and nights out there i mean
drugs were plentiful people were coming
up to us you know because we're dressed
in uh
uh in sort of the the appropriate attire
for the chas
and people were coming to us there's at
one point a guy came up to me with a a
trash can lid that was turned upside
down
and he had just various types of drugs
on it everything from weed to shrooms to
stuff that i didn't even know about
and he was just hey do you want some
partake my brethren right and then he
sort of just
he was on on rollerblades and he just
skated off to somewhere else that was
the kind
of atmosphere you had in there there was
a homeless encampment where drugs were
absolutely plentiful that led to people
getting killed people getting stabbed in
that homeless camp
so i mean this was a huge part and
parcel of exactly what was going on
because
partially it specifically with chaz it
wasn't even so much
that it was the activist bringing it in
from antifa but once you told people
that hey there's a
crime free or you know i should say a
law law enforcement free area
those criminal elements those drug
elements all of that was coming and
congregating within that chat zone
i keep going to you as the young person
get giving me some hope here
but do you think that young people are
watching this going
ah maybe law and order ain't that
terrible maybe we should
actually fund police maybe we should
arrest people for
committing murder and that sort of thing
i would
certainly hope so but i think the issue
is is that social media
mainstream media and even now our public
schooling systems are pushing
children and young people to be these
sort of radical
vessels for the left and as much as the
left wants to say that
schools are a school-to-prison pipeline
right now they are a school to
radicalism pipeline
and they are teaching the children this
sort of ideology the gender theory the
crt
and it is pushing them to act like the
antifa members out in portland and it's
very unfortunate and it's something that
has really run rampant within portland
schools through the research that i've
done
and i think we're leaning more towards
that within our public institutions and
that's where young people are being
influenced
i think in short we got work to do